it's it's very special to be here both
to be with all of you but to be here
with dr. Barrett there's no this no
smarter more committed individual that
when you're Dean and I don't wish that
on any of you when you when you get to
be Dean you you get the privilege of
having relationships in getting to know
faculty and that they're very special
and certain faculty stick out in your
mind and Michelle is is one of the more
certainly one of the more memorable and
when she wrote and said would you come
there was no question so and welcome to
you to be how long you been here 19
month two months the I assume
multinationals as multinational
corporations as opposed to all the other
multinational institutions so we're
let's assume for the moment we're a
multinational global food company and
pick a year say this is 10 years ago and
we and we're one of the largest
multi-national global food bony's what's
our business plan let's see if we can do
this right here so come up with a
business plan what's our strategy so
what's a goal
but buy cheap okay sell what sell a lot
okay at the highest process everybody
agree with that I remember but what's my
objective what do I have to do what's
what what's my fiduciary responsibility
what I really is I care about stuff my
stock price right in order to care about
my stock price what do I got to do I got
to maximize profits okay so if I going
to maximize profits i got two choices
right one of my two choices I can
maximize my revenue right or I could I
could lower my cost right and so we're a
food company right I mean what's the
business point and we're global right
and we make highly processed foods means
what what's in my food what high
fructose corn syrup what else but I not
a lot of people by high fructose corn
syrup okay right so what do I need
besides the high fructose corn syrup
okay to get to this preservatives high
fructose corn syrup and preservatives
because I want to do what I want to ship
this over oh I want to ship this over
long distances all right so what else do
I need besides high fructose corn syrup
fat kind of fat what kind of oils okay
so sorry I have cheap fats I have high
fructose corn syrup I have preservatives
what else do I got to be able to put in
these you bought this you you can pass
these around
right well we'll get to these later just
put them around anyone right what
village okay and but what's our strategy
anyone could do that and everyone else
has done that what's our business plan
we're going to make it taste good okay
so what I'm going to do I'm going to add
flavors I'm in a visual appeal okay what
else am I going to do we're global what
well what's our business plan make
people want it okay how am I going to do
that yeah but ok what the maser create
an effective response how am I going to
do that okay so I'm gonna I wouldn't do
that would I so I'm going to increase
its not just a little sort of old okay
so it says so I'm going to do with the
food itself easily accessible right what
does that mean anywhere anytime what
does that mean I mean I used to eat win
right so the business plan is to take
fat sugar and salt right make it so that
people want it make it super stimulating
at fat sugar and salt but I want to make
it accessible anywhere anytime but you
know I I do I have to eat anytime when
do I need to eat what
but I'm hungry when I see food what when
I need to eat how much do i need to eat
well I mean the what I average person
2,000 calories right over 24 hour period
probably need what during waking hours
no more than 200 calories a day an hour
right but your plan is what you want me
to eat more whether I need it or not
right but you're going to do that how by
serve but is that going to save you
money or not save you money on your
cause what they're going to make it look
bigger but it you can't make it look
bigger than it's not bigger you can use
more cost of goods or not less cost good
the way we've got to come up with a plan
here okay this is this is this is
you got to have a business plan we're
going to we're going to take fat sugar
and salt we're going to make it
stimulating right we're going to make it
attractive and then we're going to do
what with it we're going to we're going
to put it on TV 24 hours and where else
we're going to do it what do you mean
make it addictive well there's a
substance that's addictive is your only
one substance that's addictive wait a
second wait a second is everybody second
is that part of your business plan what
I said wait a second I mean in the
boardrooms of the major multinational
are people sitting there and when we
talk about your talk about their
business strategy saying we're going to
make this more addictive you think
there's any corporation that talks that
way you have any proof of that what what
just and and what did they tell you they
didn't tell you anything
and I'm going to make this accessible 24
7 right because my goal is to get what
my goal is to sell more product and get
people to do what buy it all the time
whether I need it or not right so if you
look at the business plans of the major
multinationals right it's mean if you
look privately it is you know certainly
make food highly stimulating make food
cheap be able to ship it over long
distances but make food highly
accessible the major goal has been
distribution accessible 24 7 and market
the hell out of it White's accessibility
widespread social acceptability okay
that's what's been going on over the
last 10 years okay that's the business
plan let me tell you how I got into this
and then um they the interaction when I
got called into the boardroom of a major
multinational and what I said to them
and what they said to me but I didn't
realize what was going on in the is the
business plans but these companies have
had business plans right let me tell you
how I got into this as Michelle said
like Barry said it did tobacco sitting
in my office to Yale minding my own
business just very interested not an
obesity a non include interested in a
very different question I'm assuming
with a group of residents and fellows
and asked the question if you want to
stay alive what can you do to stay alive
what's the evidence-based literature on
on prevention and I started asking that
question and a funny thing happened to
me that this is before everything was
online that one of the librarians at
Yale was
we pull the evidence-based literature
and I noticed she lost 30 pounds while
she was doing it right because I mean it
is a clinician we all know the way it's
not good for us but if you really look
at the three leading you know
three-quarters of us are going to die
for me either cancer cardiovascular
disease or stroke right three quarters
of the population and if you look
certainly what the you know one of the
major determinants of that is I mean its
excess calories right so but then I
started going ok if its excess calories
what's change ok so I call my friend
Catherine flagel and I said she's one of
the great epidemiologists at CDC so here
is age and here's weight in kilograms
and you never plot data like this but
since she's one of the great
epidemiologists I'll let her get away
with it so this I said explain to me
wait over a lifetime how is it change
right so here is back in the 1960s and
hanes one you'd enter your adult years
you'd gain a few pounds right between
your 20s and your 40s you basically stay
flat and then you lose a few pounds in
your senior years wait was relatively
stable over an adult lifetime right
that's in the 1960s here's the 1970s
here's the 1990s here's two thousand so
what's changed what's happened you keep
on gaining weight throughout your adult
here certainly much later but what do
you notice on these graphs what you see
so you where's the weight gain occurring
right before this courage you enter your
adult Europe is about 18 pounds heavier
okay it can't be genetics because jeans
don't change in three four decades and
so I was very interested in what was
driving that was curve and this is this
is overweight this is obese the percent
of population and with the exception of
Mexico the rest of the world is looking
at us and saying we don't want to look
like them and who's the them them is us
I mean it's Americans because we
certainly lead here again in overweight
but you can see that the rest of the
world is is certainly following to a
significant degree right and these
changes have happened over the last
three four decades right so the question
is what happened right why did you see
those just between the 1960s and 2000 or
less three four decades because week if
you look we didn't have a problem three
four decades ago right you know the term
set point right what's set point what's
a set point in med school right we used
to learn there was a set point what is
it so it's a biological point where if
you you know somewhere in your brain
somewhere in your body there's a concept
of stasis that if you reach that set
point you stay at that set point so I
don't lose please in diets don't work is
if I lose weight but I gained it back
because it's a set point well if that
were true we wouldn't be getting bigger
and bigger right if there were a set
point unless it was a set point only at
one end of the equation i'm watching i'm
at Yale it's the nighttime it's late
it's at night I'm surfing through the
channels and I'm watching the daily we
run of Oprah
and I still remember there is a woman on
the set there's a dr. Phil segment don't
get me started on dr. Phil the woman
comes up and says I eat when my husband
goes off to work in the morning I eat
before he comes home at night eplan I'm
happy I eat when I'm sad I eat when I'm
hungry I eat I'm not hungry then she
looked in the Camerons and I don't like
myself so and I'm sort of listening and
I'm trying to listen as a clinician as a
physician and saying what am i hearing
what's going on with this woman so I
want to understand what's going on with
those curves those graphs and I want to
understand what's going on with that
woman why was this woman doing what she
didn't want to be doing but she was
doing it anyway so scientifically not
having nothing to do with the industry
yeah at this point I try to just try to
understand what's going on with that
woman what's driving that woman to do
what she didn't want to be doing right
let me give you four or five pieces of
the science will put it together and
then we'll go into the board okay first
piece of science in the presence of a
varied and limitless diet animals and
people will tend to eat excessively
that's the first hypothesis in the
presence of a varied and limitless diet
animals and people will eat excessively
how do I know that this is the work of
Tony's Sclafani and Peter Rogers I think
the simplest of experiments take animals
in a cage from birth you give them lab
Chow and this is their weight gain if
early part of their life add to that
cage what's called the supermarket diet
hey what's in the American supermarket
take crackers chips chocolate bread put
it in the cage right in and limitless
way this is the weight of the animals
take away that supermarket diet and
their weight comes down to us coming all
the way so the presence of varied and
limitless diet animal and people will
tend to eat excessively
second piece of science all right what
drives one thing not liking but wanting
the vanilla milkshake what's in the
vanilla milkshake sugar is fat this
flavor which one drives wanting which
one what is one thing right it's the
motivational component right how do you
measure that in animals you see how hard
an animal will work for it right have a
little press the lever so you make it
animal press once they'll get the food
and you may compress a multiple so it's
two times or four times before they get
arrests or eight times or 16 times for
32 x 64 x 120 so you see what the break
point is how hard they'll work right or
heart in you can do it experiment with
with people how how much will they pay
right i mean the forward so how many of
you think what's the major driver when
you do the experiment how many think
it's this sweetness that's the major
driver for wanting raise your hands in
about the twenty percent of you how many
think it's the fat about thirty forty
percent of you how many think it's the
flavor nobody how many think it's all
three sweetness is the main driver but
when in fact you add fat to it it's
synergistic so next piece of science
right i said to my colleague jatana de
cherry one of the great pharmacologists
mean in the world to tana did the
seminal work back in the 1980s that
showed that all drugs of abuse heroin
morphine cocaine all stimulate brain
dopamine what does brain dopamine do
what is dopamine do what reward pleasure
but actually opening probably has more
to do with attention focusing and
learning and gating of a tent
so it's linked to the opioid circuitry
but dopamine affects whether it gates my
attention it focuses and what gaetano
found was back in the 1980s with all
drugs of abuse elevate the dopamine
circuitry and that's that's really the
main driver of addiction it's the
ability to elevate brain dopamine and
that you read any textbook but drugs of
abuse can elevate brain dopamine food
get your little bump and brain dopamine
but the second and third time you're a
away to it food didn't do it drugs
did it I said to jatana let's take fat
sugar and salt and feed it repeatedly to
animals and measure brained opens you're
going to condition the animal with brain
with the fat sugar and salt over repeat
period of time and then measure brain
dopamine and what you find in fact is
that if you don't give it repeatedly you
don't get brain you get a little bump in
brain dopamine but not the second and
third time but if you repeat it in this
is the nucleus accumbens you get it each
and every time right brain dopamine does
not decrease so the fact is that fat and
sugar fat and salt fat sugar and salt
stimulant a this is the work of the late
and Kelly these are these are the I just
show this these are the learning memory
habit and motivational circuits of the
brain what are those circuits I mean
they are not circuits just for food it's
a food works on which circuits of our
brain they work on the learning memory
habit and motivational circuits and so
why won't a drug for a diet ever really
work well it'll work effect on those
circuits but what circuits do they have
to affect the learning memory habited
motivational circuits right and the
problem is they're not selected for just
food you you need that circuitry for
other things so any drug feta means will
work whose appetite but it also you have
to give me back certain number of IQ
points because they're affecting the
learning memory habit in motivational
circuits do we use
for other activities other than just
eating last piece of science last piece
of science of that woman on Oprah what
was I hear what was I hearing from that
woman clinically right she said I eat
when I'm happy I eat when I'm sad I eat
when I'm hungry I eat when I'm not
hungry right and I can't control myself
she could surely controllers up she was
conscious but she felt like she was
living in in torment food was calling
out her so what I was hearing was a loss
of control a lack of satiation a lack of
feeling full a preoccupation of thinking
about food between meals or when you're
eating something you're thinking about
what you're going to eat next while
you're eating that or there's that pizza
box and there's one slice left what are
you you know you're thinking am I going
to get that slice right so these three
characteristic loss of control
accusation preoccupation so we did the
epidemiology with my colleague Alyssa
apple and my Cakery and we found fifty
percent of people who are obese percent
of people who are overweight twenty
percent of people who are a healthy
weight score very high on those week I
may not sound like a lot if you're
extrapolating this risk of the strap
elation that's some 70 million people so
if you have a you have this sort of you
know constellation of characteristics
right is it a disease no but you have
people feel who feel and although
millions of people who feel that they
have a hard time controlling their unit
so then what we did is we with Dana
small a colleague I wanted to understand
what was going on in those people and
what you see is we had to do the
experiment in in two phases okay we took
people who have score very high on those
three characteristics and how could you
notice I said twenty percent of those
people are healthy weight how can you
have those three characteristics and be
healthy weight who are they and they
restrained eaters who do they tend to be
higher socio-economic women right who
are conditioned right to have all those
characteristics but they've learned for
social norms and other reasons right to
compensate for further eating whether
they're living in an inner torment or
exercising ever they still self-report
those those characteristics but what we
did is we want to understand people who
scored very high on those
characteristics why do people that feel
like have a loss of control and just
where does the power of food come from
it comes from what Tyra food comes from
taste smell memories right I did here's
chip kid did this cover I didn't really
swing the great graphic designers
there's books of just his covers it's
not a pitch for the book but what grabs
you if you understand this cover you
understand the neuroscience of eating
right because here is what you see
there's a cat piece of carrot cake in
this carrots right what grabs your
attention what do you look at right when
you see this what grabs your attention
which which stimulus is salient and what
we found so the power of food comes from
the anticipation right and in fact where
does that happen as far as
neurologically the amygdala and
everybody queues I mean the emotional
response that happens in all of us right
but what you what we find is there's
excessive activation in people who have
this condition hyper eating in the
amygdala when you cue them and when they
start eating it continues to you see
this excessive ad activation in the
emotional response in the amygdala when
they're actually eating the food so
there's a biological coral it any to
that condition hyper eating
so you tell people who have a hard time
eating right you show them this and they
go I've always sort of have known this
but there is a you know all of a sudden
they go you mean it's not my fault
there's a reason why that stimulus has
become you know so arousing it's so
salient that it can activate it
literally it's stimulating their brain
and once you activate that amygdala what
happens you have this increase attention
increase focus these thoughts of wanting
to try to stop it and you know that's
the stuff of cravings right so let me
just see if I can just put it together
right so I get call to so we did the
signs and then I get called one of the
multinationals so I get flown to London
first class and they say what's going on
okay and I start talking to them right
and it's quite clear that this is their
business plan okay Ted fat you're in
Seoul put it on every corner make it
available twenty-four-seven make it
socially acceptable to eat anytime
that's their business plan so then I
show them just a couple of slides and I
don't go into all the side atta but I
basically say look we're all wired to
focus on the most salient stimulants the
way our brains work so if a bear walks
in here you'll stop thinking about me
you start thinking about that bear right
there's a fire next door you start
thinking about the fire okay that's
that's the way you know our brains are
designed as a species palatable food
becomes hot stimuli the food industry
has created food to be highly salient
stimulant this is a I was outed by the
washington post this is not far from
your high to go dumpster diving this is
chilis this is what's injected this
isn't what this is not what is cooked on
the top and this isn't the sauce this
isn't what it's cooked with this is
actually what's put
in the chicken and these big tumblers
some of their vacuum injected sometimes
they needle so this is so you look at
what's added to the chicken so it's
orange juice which is what lemon bar mix
what is it triple sec soybean oil soul
right that's being added I me in to the
chicken so what I'm sitting there and I
say food is designed to achieve a
remarkable salience or prominence in our
minds that individuals are vulnerable to
cues and stimuli those cues and stimuli
create urges and thoughts of wanting
choose activate the brain circuitry the
guide behavior and the behavior becomes
rewarding and self-sustaining and then I
said to them they're all there Olin
suits um let me let me give you an
analogy to bring this point home their
similarities with the analogies but
there's also some differences right but
I say it just so you understand nicotine
nicotine is a moderately reinforcing
chemical animals will work for nicotine
they don't work that doesn't drive them
to work that much room but if you add
the smoke right what did we do we added
this smoke the throat scratch the
cellophane crinkling of the pack the
color of the pack the image of the
cowboy that sends certainly my parents
and my grandparents generation that
smoking was cool it was sexy what did we
do we took a reinforcing chemical and we
made it into a highly addictive product
I give you a pitch of sugar and say go
have a good time you will say what are
you talking about add to that sugar fat
add texture add color add mouthfeel at
temperature right add add heat you know
put those chocolate chunks in it put it
on every corner make it available
twenty-four-seven and the emotional
gloss of address on advertising say you
can do it with your friends walk into
any foo
Mall in the United States walk and what
do you say we're living in a food
carnival what did we expect to happen
and your business plan listed to make
food highly salient super salient right
and to put it on every corner and made
it socially acceptable up until recently
the friend should not we're talking over
the last hour at French have not gotten
fat why because they they ate highly
palatable foods but they ate during
certain periods of time they had certain
boundaries there were certain controls
multinationals moved in and what did
they do they made food mobile they made
food accessible 24 7 they had
restaurants available food available all
the time they changed the social norm I
showed the science and made the analogy
there was absolute silence in the room
and then somebody quietly said
everything that made us successful as a
company is the problem is the problem
took fat sugar and salt put it on every
corner made it socially acceptable made
us you know so they were constantly
being stimulated does it affect
everybody no but it certainly affects
enough people i mean people who mean for
whom that past learning and past memory
is able to capture and hijack certain
part of their brain now you're that
multinational and then you say re
kessler what are we going to do what do
you advise
and that was the you know what would you
say to them that diets going to work why
why aren't I it's going to work chori
sure diets will work for 30 days 60 days
90 s you could deprive yourself but if
you've not I mean once you lay down the
new neural circuitry if you've let not
write once that circuitry to lay down
you then go on a diet then you go back
into your environment and you get cute
again what's going to happen you're
going to gain the weight back so diets
are not going to work it'd be great or
you solve ibooks you even people by diet
books because they'll never work but you
they'll have this cycle bit until you
know the natural circuitry of being able
to be captured by highly salient stimuli
what do you do if you're a multinational
you call it healthy so i'm going to i'm
going to call this healthier i'm going
to sell healthy
I've taken their goal is it to decrease
if we invited PepsiCo along with me ok
so then ask him Esther when are they
coming so so so what so when are they
coming service so ask him about Mexico
asking what part of the caloric burden
in Mexico is due to soft drink from what
the the average child in Birmingham
Alabama drinks how much sweetened
beverage a day hey so Kelly bar now our
colleague at Yale right has the
specifically has the soft drink industry
in the crosshair because what is it what
are they selling this sugar water is not
going to do it for you ok so to
understand what do they sell understand
how does it work it's a multi-sensory
product it has the reinforcing sweetness
right but you have to add to it certain
other levels of stimuli kool aid will
work for kids all right because kids
like you know one or two stimuli but you
tend to obituary so you got to add your
got to make it a super stimuli add to
the the sweetness it's not just sugar
water right so you add carbonation
you're at a mile pharmacological effect
in the key you add the temperature right
so you have a multi sensory stimuli
what's the social redeeming that what's
the nutritional value of it so what's
socially responsible about selling a
product like somebody makes the argument
please people people why do people want
it sweetness works right it it activates
the amygdala right you know so I asked
which rawson right sorry this is going
to sound inflammatory I said rich is one
of the great drug abuse experts down at
UCLA but can you make me into a meth
addict you make me want math said
absolutely I mean if I expose you to it
right I said no no no I can't you're not
going to admit you can't make me to
method he says I can make it turn that
back so one thing alone right is that
the you only give consumers what they
want and PepsiCo knows that it's in the
crosshead I mean the strategy of PepsiCo
over the is trying to move away from the
soft drinks and to diversify it knows
that it's probably you have time limited
and it has to end you know that they're
not selling you know what percentage of
their portfolio is moved away from soft
drinks I mean but Kelly has targeted I
mean is number of others in the public
health community soft drinks from number
one and they're not going to stop and
what are they going to do they're going
to mean so how do you bring this under
control
so the first thing you do is what I mean
what happened you look at pepsico
history what did they do what do they
come out and support was the first thing
they do what know what this is a problem
loud wat if we could all just wha what
extra so all the exercise programs is
just just let's all exercise and then
you can drink anything you want right so
the food industry went there first right
so I mean what i tol I said look you
have a choice I mean it's coming you're
going to either be in the crosshairs or
you know you can try to get a little
ahead of it I mean is you what's your
obligation what's your responsibility
what well is that true what's long-term
shareholders right or is that what a
corporation hides behind right well
whatever what do you sell what are you
going to do
wow you have to make a decision you're
in that boardroom right juice is any
better than what about portion size can
you decrease portion size is that is
that a public health good all in favor
of decreasing portion size raise your
hand right and what do you think what do
you think when the average consumer
walks down the aisle and see decrease
portion size that means I mean you're
going to reduce your price you are you
you're you're in the boardroom diet why
so its sweetness that stimulates the cns
it's it has the same effect on I mean
it's a sensory stimulus right
you really that manipulator you know I'm
going two by two I mean it means you I
mean some company it means some
companies that I've talked to I mean
have really seriously thought about how
do we build in speed bumps right okay so
how in whether it things are
individually packet maybe is there
anything wrong with selling something to
taste that even if it doesn't have any
nutritional value dr. Baron
well it's not illegal right so and
people are going to buy it and I can
make money doing it right and I'm going
to export this to where well so I mean
cuz I'm in durban sat I mean I chair the
board of the bouquets and pediatric AIDS
Foundation and I say to my colleagues
I'm just there on other business and I
say what I'm going to do around
especially the health workers lower
lower paid health workers and I see the
obesity in Durban and the answer from
one of my colleagues was it's KFC soon
as KFC moves to town right people use
the discretionary income then I go up to
kwazulu-natal in the northern province I
could show you there's no KFC right and
the senior matriarch of the family are
what that they are big right because
they're culturally that means what to
them that social norm said well that
means what that's that that's health
that's I'm not infected right I'm going
to provide the stability then you go how
can you be obese and there's no KFC and
then you go look and you see they have
that you know that it's called vaught
cake so it's honey and fried dough so
they make their own KFC in essence every
society has I mean it's highly salient
stimuli now the question is so from a
public policy perspective let's see if
we can agree on the legitimate role of
government right and if we can't figure
out what our responsibility is in the
boardroom full disclosure of what's in
the product everybody in favor raise
your hand is that a legitimate role of
government not a legitimate role of
government though your colleague next to
you trade secrets right but but do you
think it's a legitimate role of
government to have this cool
so that we can agree on okay um
education of in schools satta legitimate
role of government no it doesn't work
doesn't what is a legitimate role of
government education all in favor of
that is not going to work what about
taxes or what about taxes on PepsiCo
take the vote and then you can report
back all in favor of raising taxes on
soft drinks raise your hand anyone
opposed why that's that's where the line
is there is and how do those things get
decided right lobbying there will
there's no question there will be a soda
tax okay PepsiCo may not want a soda tax
right but what would you think policy
will drive that question no it will be
when the taxing authorities need the
revenue right enough and they have to
find something that they could tax it's
never the public health side that's
going to drive it but it will get there
uh so it is it is not equitable right I
mean if I you know to sense to me is not
saying the thing is to sense to you
right but is that the way the tax sales
tax system is based in tobacco did we do
it we did it work the taxes work in
tobacco absolutely right i mean you
Phillip Morris knew exactly what their
the amount of sales who would be
decreased I mean our public policy
measures perfect no right to open up
questions are we going to meet what are
we going to do about this can we get out
of this there's a country what's at
stake is this some academic exercise I
was on personal responsibility okay
great so if I just if I just you know
wake up and I control my eating right
and I exerted some personal
responsibility problem will go away how
many believe that raise your hand this
isn't matter for the this is how many
believe this is an issue of personal
responsibility primarily right how many
do not believe it's an issue of personal
responsibility so what's what's the
downside about personal well first of
all if my amygdalas being activated and
show you that and now I'm a
five-year-old right do I personal
responsibility in this game so who has
the person
responsibility the manufacturer the
parent both along with the personal
responsibility argument is a response to
of course it's a person responsible can
I I control my eating can I try to pray
Nazz being hijacked doesn't mean I can't
try to protect myself it may be hard and
may be difficult my a Mingo over maybe
hijack right as some of my colleagues
disagree with me you talked to Kelly
Brownell he will probably say mean and
others will say you're living in a
fantasy world Kessler you don't that
once you understand that the brain is
being hijacked by these food cues and
what she has done is put these food cues
every 10 feet you can't walk more than
10 20 feet from here and without having
some kind of food or food q when just
look in the room food Zara right so your
brain is constantly being hijacked right
and you expect me to protect myself at
activation and they say unless you test
unless you change the environment
dramatically you are not going to be
able to cool down Oh stimuli what's the
problem wherefore if you buy the
personal responsibility argument
certainly you can try to cool down
emotional stimuli doesn't mean your caps
you could substitute other things
parents can do it for their kids right
what's the problem if we buy the
personal responsibility argument I know
these are you don't know you don't think
the average person knows what to eat and
what second
so is this just go back to you sir first
again to the second is this a question
of knowing this question of knowledge
but what part of the brain is being
activated the emotional core of the
brain and that emotional core of the
brain I mean can i lecture you and tell
you what to eat will that affect whether
you respond your amygdala gets activated
social norms can have an effect on
whether my amygdala lights up yes okay I
mean so how did that work what did we do
what's the example tobacco what did we
do so a stimulus a reinforcing stimulus
can either be positively or negatively
valence tobacco used to be what
positively valence what did we do we
demonize the industry right we demonize
the product we made the product
negatively valence right well so cut out
but that's can I demonize food so you
can't even I mean that's the stuff of
the eating disorders right I mean if I
if I demonize who food has to be
pleasurable people need need food so the
question is can you do certain set can
you demonize are we better off
celebrating I mean which works better I
mean if you're going to stimulate the
effective core we saw alice ward is
consider and get excited about a radish
and say the radish is the greatest thing
and that will stimulate her effective
core or my better of demonizing
processed foods the problem with the
personal responsibility argument right
is that it it can only go so far because
it doesn't deal with the environment and
if the environment is set up so that I'm
constantly being cubed you're not
addressing that that problem right III
it's interesting we all hear a lot about
personal responsibility
there's not a lot we here in general in
political terms about corporate
possibility you got yet another point I
cut you off but in danger but it again I
know what I should I can assure you i
know what i should eat right but i have
suits in every size right knowledge
alone is not enough this is that mean
that me this really does deal with the
the effective core surely there are
people with disorders of their emotions
can we look at it there there wait there
yeah so Chris only know but you have
clever Bucy syndrome I mean I mean you
do have certain as soon as you have
frontotemporal dementia where windows
where those links are broken and where
the obituaries additive and they keep on
eating of course of course I mean I mean
if you're the ideal if you want to sell
the ideal product what's the ideal
product in this world what so translate
over what but what do you want to
trigger no translate that into
physiological terms so I'm trying to get
and what is that what's an addictive
substance use the word addictive
substance what's in a dick what why what
makes it addictive well we're dopamine
is a chemical okay right something
doesn't change shake it right right the
whole market of addictive substance is
something something that lets use the
term rewarding okay reinforcing is
something that can change how you feel
right so the goal of if I'm going to
sell something right the most
importantly you look at most marketing
and advertising next to a product this
it tries to associate with some kind of
experience that changes how you feel
right so something's going to make me
feel better right something's going to
allow me to escape something's kind of
right I don't you know I'm stressed this
is going to make me feel better right so
what if drugs of abuse do why does why
do people get addicted they want to feel
better problem is those circuits get
hijacked by the drugs and then they get
queued and then they get the arousal and
then they get the intro to get locked
into this cycle so the drug is actually
making them feel worse and but they
won't need the drug can order to feel
them make them feel better so so what
what you want to do the ultimate product
is something that's going to make
somebody feel better and at the
effective core and in the absence of
making it somebody feel better what do I
do I try to market in advertised so I
put poison the food right so there's
something that I want that's going to
make me feel good even and I learned to
associate it with the food yeah
so right should understand how it so if
you have passed learning and past
experience right you have to have a
memory right you've had that and that's
made you feel good right that's given
and there's a pleasurable response and
something associated with that ques mini
right and then that Q stimulates you
know certain arousal and attention right
and then that's before I eat that's just
a cue right so I I just see the ad right
and I start thinking about it I have
these thoughts right then I then I
actually consume the product i had this
momentary pleasure this is the sort of
bliss point we don't quite understand
that I mean whether it's the end
cannabinoids or the opiate and orphans
or what are the oh boy your circuitry so
i have this pleasure the next time i get
queued i do it again and every time I do
it I strengthen the neural circuitry so
I guess I get caught in this cycle is
there any satisfaction ever where's the
dopamine I mean the dopamine is probably
more associated with the queue right do
you think we think it's a serious
problem but not yet right do you have
any doubts about the seriousness of it
what let's deal with the personal it
made that's about the problem
by 2030 what's the number what's the
percent that will be type 2 diabetic by
CDC's numbers third right but but you
have people who make fun of the first
lady's efforts you have certain pundits
you know who making fun of what the
first lady's right she's basically pitch
perfect right but she gets attacked
because this is what this is the
national nanny right do we all agree we
want I mean not everybody in this room
agreed to tax well what is not happening
well sure sure susu so let's deal with
the French first then you can look first
of all there's a dirty little secret
which we don't want to talk about right
well did the French smoke all right so
at the end of the meal that given a
choice between desert or the cigarette
they want the cigarette right boot right
so talk about or at because that's
substituting one pressing behavior for
another right but up until spend the
social Norman frame what kind of food do
they what do they want on real food
right the one processed foods it would
never eat the kind of sizes were eating
a disgusting to them they would never
eat between meals they would never bring
anything into a classroom right they
have certain boundaries those boundaries
protect what did we do in the United
State what's been the business model ok
Taco Bell what's the what's let me go
back to the business model we agreed
upon what's the tagline right so the
business plan right has such I mean did
you have any doubts wide that I mean if
you're going to take fat sugar and salt
and put it on every corner and make it
available twenty-four-seven to make it
socially acceptable to getting time and
make food into entertainment what we
think was going to happen the problem is
once you lay down the circuitry once you
lay down this past learning in past
memory and this year this Q induced
circuitry right and it's activating the
end of the emotional core of the brain
and that's how it's working can you
reverse that so we just I yeah I mean I
was on a panel I think I said it you
know for diabetologist i showed the data
and they basically said we're toast as a
country how do you change that right
right so the question is what you say to
the multinational company and the
question is is it true to understand
their or certain what we see evolving
because it has to have the same degree
of emotional response if you're going to
substitute something for fat sugar and
salt you're going to have to something
that can stimulate that amygdala and
people wanted as much as the fat your
insult right and so that's the Sufis of
people caring about something so some
people care about whether it's the
ethical treatment of animals eating
organic eating locally eating real food
so the question is is there a food
movement there's certainly many food
movements that are occurring in this
country and the question is where is the
social norm right and i think i think it
starts certainly we're not America here
I mean I mean on the two coasts all
right so you can't judge certainly I
mean in the bay area right this is not
America right but there's certainly an
increased emphasis I mean I'm going to
eat you know I just will you walk down
the streets of you know major cities
these days and they're all the places to
get real food I mean are increasing
and so the mean if we've effectively
demon and the question is do we
celebrate the good stuff where do we
demonize the bad stuff and which is more
effective right the social norm wait I'd
be happy to stick around to answer any
others how do we take the second
question right the first question is a
little easier than the others I mean we
all need to eat right and chances are I
think what you see is it increasingly
and it still needs to be tested people
are willing to spend a little more of
their discretionary income certainly in
other countries for a better food so I
mean what we're talking about it's not
the economy right it just may be
changing who does the money go to so
where do I spend the Democratic Party
understands this I mean this is an issue
of they understand for example that you
can't get you can't become president of
the United States unless you have a
certain percentage of the rule boat and
who's the rural vote or made a lot of it
as farmers right and I mean in those
farmers right so eating locally eating
real food I mean who wears you know
that's quite
who's going to win and who's going to
lose I don't think the issue is hurting
to come the second question is a much
harder question and that is this issue
of real food is going to cost more than
highly processed foods because the
advantage over the if you look what's
happened in the 1930s and 1940s in order
to feed a hungry nation what did we do
right we learn to process foods so we
learn to take food take water out of it
add preservatives into it increase shelf
life ship it over long distance cheaper
food along the way we learn to dial in
fat sugar and salt the flavors were able
to make the stuff bad food even look
good right we took out anything
objectionable of the food so that it so
that we ate food without it's nothing
slow we used to chew 20 30 times per
bite today the food goes down after one
and two two bites we're all eating adult
baby food I mean it was the highly
processed food has been designed so it's
just we're self stimulating ourselves so
we we've made this processed food we
were able to make it very cheap sell it
over long distances real food is more
expensive right how do you how do you
get to afford that right the issue is if
I just keep on this treadmill I'm not
sure I agree with the premise right that
real food has to be more expensive
because if I'm just eating crap all the
time and I'm just eating it non-stop and
it's not satiating me am I better off I
mean you know that bag of chips and I
I'm just going to eat another bag of
chips later on or am I better off eating
that are inch is going to cost more than
that bag of chips I mean I think the
real food doesn't necessarily over the
long term have to be much more expensive
but calorie for calorie it's going to
look more expensive thank you very much